Sind Sie zufrieden mit dem,
was Sie haben?
Dürfte es mehr sein?
Haben Sie das Gefühl, glücklicher
zu sein, wenn Sie mehr hätten?
Diese Frage klären wir.
"Reporter Spezial -
Macht Geld glücklich?"
* Entspannte Gitarrenmusik *
Wir sind im Berner Oberland.
In dieser Hütte,
Sie haben ihn schon gesehen,
wohnt der Eremit Christoph Trummer.
Er sagt von sich, er sei glücklich,
obwohl er nichts habe,
oder gerade darum,
weil er nichts habe.
* Entspannte Gitarrenmusik *
Es ist ein verhangener Sonntagmorgen.
Was macht dich glücklich,
wenn du hier bist?
Mein Herz.
Dass mein Herz noch schlägt,
dass es noch atmet.
Dass ich hier bin,
dass es mich gibt.
Das ist das Glück.
Ja.
Und ich bin heute
glücklich für mich selbst,
dass mich das glücklich macht.
Das ist Glück,
das ist noch das höhere Glück,
dass mich das glücklich macht.
Das ist nicht selbstverständlich.
Nein.
Du hast einen
komplett anderen Weg eingeschlagen
als die meisten von uns
und anders, als er vorgesehen war.
Ich habe einfach
die linke Seite des Lebens genommen,
die anderen nehmen die rechte Seite.
Wie diese linke Seite aussieht
und wie man dorthin kommt,
zu einem Leben als Eremit,
wie es Christoph Trummer führt,
zeigt unser Reporter Simon Christen
in einem kurzen Film.
* Wasserrauschen *
* Gitarrenmusik
und rhythmisches Trommeln *
Ein Leben im Bachbett der Engstligen
nahe Frutigen im Berner Oberland -
allein und ohne Besitz.
* Gitarrenmusik
und rhythmisches Trommeln *
Warum?
Es geschieht mit mir.
So.
Einfach ...
Um zu mir selbst zu kommen.
Um ...
Um mir selbst näher zu kommen.
Eigentlich.
Und ...
Um aus dem Lärm
in die Stille zu kommen.
In jahrelanger Arbeit
baute er sich ein Refugium auf:
einen Ort des einfachen Lebens
und hohen Denkens, sagt er.
Ein kleines Paradies
für einen Adam mit wechselnden Evas.
Ja ...
Ich mag Frauen sehr gern.
Die Frau ist ein wunderbares Wesen.
So.
Es überwältigt mich
immer wieder aufs Neue.
Es erquickt mich -
allein schon der Anblick.
Die Nähe zu sehen.
Wie nahe die Frau dem Herzen ist.
Sie ist dem Herzen einfach
einen Schritt näher als wir Männer.
Wir sind einfach im Kopf ...
Trummer wusste schon
als Jugendlicher,
dass er nie eine Familie wollte.
Er wollte frei sein,
was noch lange nicht heisst,
dass er ein Kostverächter ist.
Im Herzen sei und bleibe er
aber Eremit, ein Einsiedler,
der mehr oder weniger abgeschieden
von den Menschen lebt.
* Niederprasselnder Regen *
Wir sind alle
mit der Einsamkeit konfrontiert.
Wir gebären allein,
wir sterben allein.
Wir leben allein.
Auch wenn wir mit Tausenden Menschen
leben, sind wir trotzdem allein.
Trummer machte sich
mit Anfang 20 auf den Weg,
um nichts weniger
als den Sinn des Lebens zu finden.
Über Umwege landete er in Indien,
wo ihm alle Sachen gestohlen wurden.
Für ihn ein Zeichen,
alles loszulassen.
Also meldete er sich nicht
bei der Schweizer Botschaft,
sondern lebte monatelang auf der
Strasse - und war danach ein anderer.
Als er alles Materielle
verloren hatte, merkte er,
dass er etwas gewonnen hatte:
Freiheit.
Frei von Angst,
frei von Existenzangst.
Frei von ... Einfach frei!
24 Std. den Tag offen zu haben,
machen können, was man will.
Dorthin gehen, wo man will.
Niemand ist da.
Man hat auch keine Sehnsucht
nach irgendjemandem. Nichts.
Einfach frei.
Man ist mit sich zusammen.
Man ist mit seinem Herzen unterwegs.
Trummer zieht es
immer wieder unter Menschen.
Etwa nach Frutigen,
wo er geboren wurde
und wo er noch heute
ein Winterquartier hat.
Opela, opela.
Das Verhältnis zu seiner
inzwischen verstorbenen Mutter
war nicht immer einfach.
Er habe Frieden geschlossen
mit seiner Vergangenheit,
auch mit seiner
unglücklichen Jugendzeit.
Das war v.a. in der Pubertätszeit.
Das hat sich so geäussert,
dass es so weit ging,
dass der kleine Junge da
sich das Leben nehmen wollte.
Ach.
- Doch.
So.
Zum Glück hast du es nicht gemacht.
Das wäre das Schlimmste gewesen.
Nicht, dass ich ...
Ja, das ist klar.
Wussten Sie das?
Nein, davon merkte ich nie etwas.
Er war immer ein fröhlicher Junge.
Ich war immer feinfühlig.
Ich war keiner für die Schule,
um dort eingesperrt zu werden.
Trummer stammt aus einer
evangelikalen Arbeiterfamilie.
Er war das fünfte von sieben Kindern.
Er schloss seinen Eltern zuliebe
eine Lehre als Elektriker ab
und machte die RS,
dann brach er aus, bis nach Indien.
Und als er von da zurückkehrte,
war aus dem lieben Buben
ein junger Mann geworden,
den seine Familie
kaum wiedererkannte.
Wir hatten das Gefühl,
er habe Mühe,
sich in unsere Kultur
zu integrieren.
Er hat einfach ...
Er hängt fest an dem,
was er dort erlebte.
Jeder empfindet das für sich.
Trummer ist handwerklich begabt.
Seine Dienste
sind in und um Frutigen gefragt.
Er hat dem Staat deshalb
noch nie auf der Tasche gelegen.
Er arbeitet allerdings nur so viel,
dass er seine rund 500 Fr. Fixkosten
im Monat decken kann,
und nimmt nur Aufträge an,
die er sinnvoll findet.
Es sind kleine Tätigkeiten
im einfachen Rahmen.
Viel auch für alte Leute,
ihnen etwas helfen und so.
Das macht Sinn.
Und dabei schaut das Nötige raus,
damit ich mein einfaches,
bescheidenes Leben
auch finanziell führen kann.
Und immer schön
an den Steuern vorbei?
Selbstverständlich
gehe ich an den Steuern vorbei.
Aber nicht in dem Sinn ...
Mehrwertsteuer bezahle ich auch.
Bei jedem Brötchen, Joghürtchen etc.
bezahle ich die gleichen Steuern.
Einkommenssteuer hingegen -
man muss zuerst so viel verdienen.
Über das Existenzminimum rauskommen.
Das, was man mehr verdient,
als man braucht -
es ist richtig,
dass das richtig versteuert wird.
Trummer lebt noch immer im Bachbett,
ist kürzlich 64 geworden und sagt,
er sei und bleibe glücklich.
Das Glück ist wie ein Schatz,
der in sich selbst vergraben ist.
Man ist schon glücklich, wenn man
weiss, dass der Schatz in einem ist.
Das wahre Glück hat man erst dann,
wenn man den Schatz halten
und anwenden kann.
Wenn man davon leben kann.
Anzuhäufen lohnt sich nicht.
Zum Zeitpunkt des Todes
lässt man ohnehin alles gehen.
Also wozu?
* Flötenklänge *
Jeden Atemzug,
den wir erleben können,
bewusst erfahren.
Die Dankbarkeit und Liebe
zu erfahren, die darin liegt,
das ist mehr als Glück.
Das ist Glückseligkeit,
die wir da erfahren.
* Schräge Flötenklänge *
(Mona) Diese Sorte Glück
ist auch etwas ...
Sie ist etwas Egoistisches -
es geht nur um dich.
Ja, sicher.
Das ist doch nicht so.
- Doch.
Im Leben geht es auch um Beziehungen
zu anderen.- Das ist möglich.
Wenn jeder und jede ...
Würde jeder zuerst für sich schauen,
dann wäre für alles geschaut.
Du sagst, Kinder zu haben ...
Ein Familie zu haben,
Verantwortung zu übernehmen,
ist so, wie du lebst, nicht möglich.
Das ist auch ...
- Das ist meine Wahl.
Ja.
Warum soll ich
Verantwortung für etwas übernehmen,
das ich nicht will?
Das ist meine Wahl.
- Das ist vermutlich der Grund,
warum die meisten Menschen
anders leben als du.
Deshalb kann ich viele Dinge
für die Gesellschaft machen.
So wie jetzt z.B. hier:
Rede und Antwort zu stehen
und und und ...
Das ist auch für alle.
Das ist dann auch für alle.
In einer Gesellschaft braucht es
verschiedene Gewürze, Kräuter,
damit es
ein bisschen interessant wird.
Ich bin das Kräutchen, das ich bin.
Und es wird auch gebraucht.
Wozu? Was hast du zu geben?
Was ich zu geben habe? Meine Zeit.
Zeit.
Um zuzuhören,
Tee zu machen.
Ich gebe meine Zeit, sonst habe ich
eigentlich nichts zu geben.
Was ich habe, das gebe ich auch.
Wenn du frierst,
kannst du das haben.
Aber sonst habe ich nichts zu geben.
Ich habe nichts.
Was denkst du über jene Menschen,
eigentlich die meisten von uns,
die ein konventionelles Leben führen,
die Karriere machen wollen
und evtl. von einem Häuschen träumen
und immer daran arbeiten.
Wie schaust du das an?
Ich habe Bedauern mit ihnen.
Wir tun dir leid?
- Ja, sehr.
Ja.
Dass man das Leben
für so einen Ramsch verlebt.
So ist das Leben
zum Fenster rausgeworfen.
Aus der Sicht,
aus der ich es jetzt betrachte.
Nach Besitz zu streben ...
Leg das Herz nicht dorthin,
wo es in die Vergänglichkeit gerät,
wo es vergeht.
Man muss dort das Potenzial geben,
wo es bleibt.
Das nehmen wir nachher auch mit.
Das ist hier unsere Verwirklichung.
Was heisst das? Anstatt viel
zu arbeiten und Geld zu verdienen?
Was ist klüger?
Das Leben leben.
Essen, trinken, schlafen.
Gesundheit.
Und voilà.
Das wäre es eigentlich.
Dazu ein spirituelles Leben.
Meditieren, sich nach innen richten.
Gutes tun.
Das Leben spirituell praktizieren.
Deine Mutter wäre froh gewesen,
wenn du ein anderes Kräutchen, wenn
du etwas normaler geworden wärst.
"Normaler" ...
Dann wäre ich
so abnormal geworden wie sie.
Abnormal wie die Gesellschaft.
Wir wissen,
dass wir hier in der Schweiz
mit der Energie jetzt schon
auf Pump leben.
Bereits Anfang Mai sind wir
auf Pump, vom Fussabdruck her.
So gesagt ...
Was soll das Ganze?
Ich versuche,
möglichst
auf einem Fussabdruck zu bleiben.
Vielleicht brauche ich
mehr als einen.
Einen ökologischen Fussabdruck.
Wieso soll ich bei dem Wahnsinn mit-
machen? Ich bin einer der Normalen.
Sagst du?
- Was?
Energie für einen Fussabdruck
zu beziehen,
der mir gegeben ist.
Und nicht dreimal mehr,
das einem anderen dann fehlt.
Warum? Sie sind ...
- Ja, das stimmt eigentlich.
Da und dort nagen sie am Hungertuch.
Wir leben alle
über unsere Verhältnisse
und du bist der Einzige ...
- Nicht der Einzige.
... einer der wenigen.
- Von wenigen, ja.
Was du machst,
ist im Moment absolut im Trend.
Es gibt überall
diese Minimalismus-Bewegungen.
Menschen sagen, nur noch
mit 64 Gegenständen zu leben.
Sie predigen Achtsamkeit.
All das lebst du schon seit Jahren.
Du könntest Karriere machen als Guru,
als spiritueller Führer.
Man könnte vieles.
Ich weiss schon ...
Du spürst das auch ein wenig.
Man könnte vieles,
wenn es das Leben vorsieht.
Ich lasse das Leben mit mir machen.
Ich entscheide nicht selbst.
Ich lasse das Leben
durch mich leben.
Hat das Leben so etwas vor,
macht das Leben aus einem das,
was das Leben will.
Mehr gibt es eigentlich gar nicht.
Gibt es das für dich?
Die anderen arbeiten ein Leben lang
und werden mit 65 pensioniert.
Gibt es das bei dir auch?
Ich bin bereits mit 22
in Pension gegangen.
Mein ganzes Leben ist Pension.
Es hiess immer,
wenn man pensioniert sei,
fange man an zu leben.
Ich sagte mir: "Halt!"
"Darauf warte ich nicht.
Ich fange jetzt an zu leben."
He, ja.
So habe ich mein Leben ausgerichtet.
Ich habe mein Leben gelebt.
Wirklich gelebt. Ausgekostet.
Ich habe nichts verpasst. Nichts.
Im Grunde genommen
gibt es auch keine Vergangenheit.
Was vorbei ist, ist vorbei.
Die Zukunft ...
Was ist Zukunft?
Der Moment ist das, was zählt.
Du wirst auch nicht jünger.
Wie siehst du deine Zukunft?
Du hast keine Krankenkasse,
du lebst hier draussen.
Was denkst du, wie lange du
das noch so machen kannst?
Ich denke nichts.
Ich denke gar nichts. Wozu?
Die Zukunft spielt doch keine Rolle.
Der Moment ist wichtig.
- Ja.
Wir besuchen jemanden,
der auf einem total anderen Dampfer
unterwegs ist als du.
Art Furrer ist in einer armen
Bergbauernfamilie zur Welt gekommen.
Er sagte sich: "Ich gehe den anderen
Weg, ich arbeite mich da raus."
Er hat sich ein Restaurant-
und Hotelimperium aufgebaut.
Unser Reporter Christof Franzen
hat Art Furrer begleitet.
* Schleppende Musik *
Das ist die Riederalp im Oberwallis.
Für mich ein Heimspiel. Ich bin
auf der Bettmeralp aufgewachsen.
Den erfolgreichen Hotelier, Berg-
führer und Skiakrobaten Art Furrer
kenne ich seit meiner Kindheit,
aber persönlich haben wir
uns erst einmal getroffen.
Das ist meine Wanderausrüstung.
* Lachen *
So wie viele hier oben
hatte auch ich früher
ein ambivalentes Bild von ihm.
Furrer hat viel getan für
die Bekanntheit des Aletschgebietes.
Aber er hat auch
gerne und häufig gestritten
und war einer,
der hart austeilte.
Ich möchte erfahren, ob ihn
sein Reichtum glücklich gemacht hat.
Jetzt, wo der Mann mit dem Cowboyhut
83 Jahre alt ist.
Geld war für mich in jungen Jahren
enorm wichtig,
weil wir keines hatten.
In den 13 Jahren in den USA
konnte ich immer wieder
sehr leicht und gut
Geld verdienen.
Das erste Geld
brauchte ich hier für den Boden.
Dann habe ich angefangen zu bauen.
Ich habe viele der Wohnungen
verkauft.
Am Anfang habe ich fast alle
verkauft, auch an Amerikaner.
So hatte ich immer wieder Geld
für das Nächste.
Immer im Leben ...
Immer, wenn ich Geld hatte,
habe ich gebaut.
Meine Süchte waren
Bergsteigen und Bauen.
Diese Überbauung ...
Diese beiden Überbauungen hier
kosteten 22 Mio. Fr.
Die zwei?
- Ja.
Aber sehr gut verkauft.
Das ist das Neuste und Schönste.
So.
Jawohl.
- Oder gehen wir zu Fuss?
Haben wir Platz?
- Wir haben genügend Platz.
Hier ist es so schön.
Warum passt der nicht?
Der müsste doch passen.
Ich weiss nie, welcher wofür ist.
Du hast zu viele Häuser.
So viele Schlüssel.
Immer noch zu viele Häuser.
* Christof Franzen lacht. *
Das ist alles meine Fotokunst.
Ah, schön.
Das Dhaulagiri-Gebiet in Nepal.
Antarktis.
- Du warst dort?- Ja,ja.
So habe ich früher ausgesehen.
Das waren die 68er-Jahre.
* Art Furrer lacht. *
Meine Frau meinte:
"Entweder rasierst du dich -
oder ich gehe."
Das sind Artikel,
die ich geschrieben habe.
Zeitungen, Skimagazine.
Da ist alles Mögliche drin.
Aber chaotische Zustände -
chaotische Zustände.
Furrer hat einen Grossteil seiner Im-
mobilien seinen drei Kindern vererbt.
Aber er besitzt immer noch
Land und Wohnungen
im Wert
von mehreren Millionen Franken.
Hier sind wir in der Wohnung
seines Bruders Gregor.
Die gehört meinem Bruder.
Ich werde ihm beichten,
dass ich hier reingekommen bin.
Schau hier ...
- Die sind in Amerika erschienen?
Ja, im "Ski Magazine",
dem grössten US-Magazin.
Das gibt es immer noch.
Bei diesem Magazin war ich ...
... jahrelang Redaktor.
"Ein Schweizer begeistert mit
seiner Skiakrobatik die Amerikaner."
Hier wusste man nicht,
was ich in Amerika gemacht hatte -
und sie glaubten es auch nie.
Mit einer Olympiamedaille konnte man
sagen, man sei Olympiasieger.
Diesen Vorteil hatte ich nicht.
* Schleppende Musik *
In Amerika sorgte er mit seinem
ganz eigenen Ski-Stil für Furore.
Ein Spassvogel und Clown, der nicht
mit Kraft und auf Tempo Ski fuhr,
sondern locker und verspielt.
So machte er
die Skiakrobatik populär.
(Originalkommentar) Arthur Furrer
macht prinzipiell alles,
was im Skibüchlein verboten ist.
Nur macht er es so perfekt,
dass ihn alle Leute bewundern.
Northwest,
das war in Seattle und Vancouver.
An den Skishows
brauchten sie jemanden,
den das Publikum kannte und den man
entsprechend ankündigen konnte.
Das ist Stein Eriksen.
- Der Schwede.
Im Rating ...
Er hatte am meisten.
In den besten Jahren
verdiente ich am zweitmeisten.
waren es 800'000 ...
... bis ...
800'000 bis 1 Mio.
- Franken?
Ob ein Schranz
oder all die Österreicher ...
Keiner verdiente im Skifahren
ähnlich viel Geld wie ich.
Was war dein Erfolgsrezept?
Warum hast du so viel verdient?
PR. Die Dinge wurden alle ...
Gut verkauft?
- Ich hatte einen Namen.
Ich sagte keinem Nein,
machte überall mit.
Und er wirkte in vielen Skifilmen
und Reportagen mit.
Hier mit Helm als Stuntman.
Der mit dem Helm bist du.
- Das war ganz gut.
Das war das Ballett
auf dem Zwillingsgletscher
zusammen mit Suzy Chaffee.
Sie war eine sehr gute Balletteuse.
Schau mal, wie herzig das war.
Mit ihr ...
Schau mal,
dieser schöne Doppelschwung.
Etwas davon könnte man zeigen.
Da, da, da!
Das war super gut.
Mit ihr bin ich
sehr gut ausgekommen.
Ich habe die Frauen nie angebaggert.
Darum hatte ich
ein spezielles Verhältnis mit ihnen.
Ich hatte zehn, zwölf Mannequins
für eine Modenschau dabei.
Wir sind von Stadt zu Stadt gereist.
Ich war der Dompteur.
Hätte ich mit einer etwas gehabt,
hätte ich den Respekt verloren.
(Originalkommentar) Once upon a time
there was a lonely man
that dreamed about
a beautiful experience like this.
Furrer wurde zum Aushängeschild
von grossen Skiausrüstern,
Schnapsbrennereien
oder dem "Playboy".
Und er war Skilehrer der Promis.
Die Kennedy-Familie,
Doris Day oder Leonard Bernstein
zählten zu seinen Kunden.
Heute kennt man uns, man weiss,
dass wir aus der Schweiz sind.
Ich habe auch gespürt,
dass in den letzten Jahren
die Nachfrage nach Schweizer
Kurorten grösser geworden ist.
Dann hat er den Erfolg in die Schweiz
gebracht, wie das Gästebuch zeigt.
Das hier war der Sohn von Adenauer.
Mit ihm hier hatte ich viel zu tun.
- Karl Dall.
Karl Dall war
ein unglaubliches Unikum.
Lebt er noch?
- Ja, ja.
Ist das Sina?
- Welche? Sina? Ja.
Er war auch oft hier.
Das ist der spanische König.
- Nein, dieser hier. Das bist du.
Das ist Fabienne Serrat.
Wenn du zurückblickst: Hattest du
genügend Zeit für die Familie?
Ja, gell ...
Ach, Zeit gehabt ...
Mit der Familie
hatte ich kein Problem,
weil meine Frau zur Familie schaute.
Sie war die beste Mutter,
die es geben konnte.
Und du der beste Vater?
Ich war nicht der beste Vater,
aber ich brachte die Kohle.
Ich bin immer gut
mit der Familie ausgekommen,
aber ich war sehr oft weg.
Gerlinde hat die Familiensachen
übernommen - bestens gemacht -
und ich schaute zum Unternehmen.
Hast du das Gefühl,
dass du etwas verpasst hast?
Ja, wenn man das ...
Schau da, die Furri Hütte.
Meine Frau. Die Furri Hütte.
Die ganze Geschichte
der Furri Hütte.
Noch einmal, hast du das Gefühl,
etwas verpasst zu haben?
Ganz sicher habe ich etwas verpasst.
Aber dann hätte ich das
auch verpasst.
Was ich gearbeitet habe
und wie ich es gemacht habe ...
Zu bestimmten Zeiten
hatte es ganz sicher
zu wenig Platz für die Familie.
* Dynamische Musik:
"Cotton Eye Joe" von Rednex *
Glück? Das kommt nicht von selbst.
Das macht sich jeder selbst.
Es ist nicht programmiert
und nicht Zufall.
Das Glück macht man sich selbst,
indem man etwas will.
Wenn man etwas wirklich will und
sich daran hält, bekommt man es.
Mit seiner Frau Gerlinde
ist er seit über 50 Jahren zusammen.
Was er aufgebaut hat, kommt
von seinem Willen und Ehrgeiz.
Er kann sehr messerscharf sein -
im Business überhaupt.
Aber er ist auch
genau das Gegenteil davon.
Mein Leben
war immer voller Abwechslung.
Voller Spannung,
auch voller Kampf.
Die schönste Zeit des Lebens ...
Man denkt ja kurzfristig.
- Ja.
Während dieser Corona-Problematik
war ich mit meiner Frau
vier Wochen lang
hier und in Zermatt in Quarantäne.
So schön und so nahe wie während
dieser Zeit waren wir vorher nie.
Eine mögliche Karriere
als Skirennfahrer sei in der Jugend
am fehlenden Geld gescheitert.
Furrer
ist in bescheidenen Verhältnissen
im Bergdorf Greich aufgewachsen.
Damals noch ohne Seilbahn-
und Strassenverbindung.
In diesem Haus bin ich geboren.
- Ja.
Aber den Anbau
hat es noch nicht gegeben.
Nur den oberen Teil.
- Aha.
Wir können von unten her hinlaufen,
dann sieht man es.
Hier finden sich auch noch
Relikte seiner Streitlust.
Das ist der Kiosk,
um den ich auf der Riederfurka
jahrelang mit Blatter stritt.
Diese Buvette des Wirtepaares Blatter
stand damals
neben Furrers Restaurant.
Ein kleiner Konkurrent,
doch Furrer wollte ihn weghaben.
Formal ging es
um eine fehlende Bewilligung.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass ich ohne Bewilligung ein
Gebäude hätte aufstellen dürfen.
Ich finde das nicht korrekt von ihm.
Es ist kein juristisches Problem,
sondern ein menschliches.
Art Furrer ist voller Neid
und Missgunst
und will uns hier
mit allen Mitteln weghaben.
Das stimmt gar nicht.
Mein Krieg hier oben - wenn man
das als Krieg bezeichnen darf -
ist mit der Gemeinde Ried-Mörel und
mit unserem lieben Kanton Wallis.
Den Streit
hat er damals mit Geld gelöst.
Ich habe ihn für 700'000 Fr.
gekauft, damit er weg ist.
Danach verschenkten wir den Kiosk
an die Gemeinde.
Er wurde von der Riederfurka hierher
geflogen und ein bisschen ausgebaut.
Mit Blatter
hast du Frieden geschlossen?
Was ist?
- Mit Blatter bist du im Frieden?
Ach, weisst du,
das liegt so weit zurück.
Was will man da?
- Der Streit kam am Fernsehen.
Er hat mich sicher nicht vergessen,
aber mir ist er heute wurst.
Gibt es noch welche, mit denen du
im Unfrieden bist?- Nein.
Sehr wenige.
Es fällt mir keiner ein,
mit dem ich
nicht Frieden geschlossen habe.
Sein Vater war Jäger und Wilderer. Er
starb jung an einer Lungenkrankheit.
Arthur war damals erst 13 Jahre alt.
Und doch sei er stark
von seinem Vater geprägt worden.
Mein Vater selig sagte immer:
"Die dort unten
sehen kein bisschen besser als wir."
"Im Gegenteil, wir sind ehrlich."
"Die dort unten
haben genügend Wasser,
darum haben sie besseres Essen."
"Aber wir hier oben sind ehrlicher."
Das ist mir immer geblieben.
Dann habe ich mir
auf dieser Mauer geschworen:
"Eines Tages will ich
mindestens das Gleiche haben
wie die dort unten -
wenn möglich mehr."
"Ich will jemand sein."
Geld hatten wir sowieso keines.
Aber wir wollten auch jemand sein.
Jetzt geht es hier rüber.
- Ja.
Und jetzt ...
Jetzt muss noch alles ... Doch.
Die erste Tür ist offen.
Aha, gar nicht abgeschlossen.
Hereinspaziert!
- Man muss den Kopf einziehen.
Schlag den Kopf nicht an!
Hier könnte ich nicht stehen.
Darum bist du
nicht grösser geworden.
Früher war alles so.
- Wahnsinn.
Das ist noch original,
so wie es früher war.
Hier war immer die Grossmutter.
In diesem Zimmer habe ich gewohnt.
Aha.
Hier habe ich gewohnt.
- So? Ist das von früher?
Genauso.
Hier hat sich nichts verändert.
Das war ein modernes Möbel.
- Hier ein Foto meines Vaters.
Aktivdienst. Weisst du,
was sie im Aktivdienst machten?
Gewildert und Fleisch gebracht.
- Ach ja?
Aus dem Binntal. Mein Vater schoss
den ersten Hirsch im Oberwallis.
Ze Binne im Hotel Ofenhorn
hängt er noch an der Wand.
Gab es hier früher keine Hirsche?
Nein, die ersten Hirsche
kamen von Italien.
Er sagte dem Kadi, er hätte einen
Hirsch gesehen, einen grossen Stier.
Er fragte, was er machen sollte,
und der Kadi sagte:
"Holen! Wir brauchen Fleisch."
Die Kompanie war in der Twingi-
Schlucht. Twingi hiess es. Ja, ja.
Ach, lass das, Arthur!
- Nein, nein!
Den habe ich mitgebracht.
Jetzt trinken wir einen Schluck,
ganz klar.
Er habe im Leben fast nie
eine Interviewanfrage abgelehnt.
Seine Medienpräsenz
ist seit Jahrzehnten gross.
Das sorge für Neid.
Dann regten sie sich auf,
dass ich wieder in der Zeitung war.
Die dachten, das sei korrupt
oder ich würde sie kaufen.
Oder dieses oder jenes.
Du hast sie auch immer eingeladen.
Immer eingeladen, immer.
* Christof Franzen lacht.*
Getrunken haben sie gern.
Ich darf gar nicht sagen,
wen ich alles eingeladen habe
und wer nie etwas bezahlt hat.
Journalisten?
Ja, klar.
Aber nur, das ...
Das war damals völlig normal.
Sie machten Ferien
und du hattest danach gute Presse.
Nein, das waren Beziehungen,
die man hatte.
Wenn jemand
eine gute Sache machte ...
Hat jemand über das Aletschgebiet
geschrieben, sagte ich ihm,
wenn ich mal ein freies Zimmer habe,
könne er es haben.
Das konnte der Verkehrsverein
nicht zahlen, das zahlte immer ich.
Das habe ich in den USA gelernt,
als ich für den "Playboy" arbeitete.
Ich fragte,
warum sie so locker seien.
Sie sagten, wenn von
den zehn Einladungen eine gut sei,
habe man ein super Geschäft gemacht.
- Mhm.
Das war gang und gäbe,
das war kein Geheimnis.
Heute gibt das ein Riesentheater,
das darf man nicht.
Dass ein Bundesrat
eine Woche Ferien machte
und nie etwas bezahlte -
das geht ...
Das geht doch nicht.
Wer war es?
Das sage ich nicht.
* Christof Franzen lacht. *
Bundesräte.
- Bundesräte.
Räte.
- Das ist doch gut.
Eh, nein. Ach!
Nicht zuletzt habe ihm
die streng katholische Erziehung
Halt gegeben im Leben.
Hätte ich nicht
den roten Faden der Religion gehabt,
dass man,
wenn man vom Karren gefallen ist,
sofort wieder
auf den Karren aufsteigen muss ...
Ich wäre in Amerika verlumpt.
Verlumpt?
- Ja.
Wieso?
Auf Abwege geraten.
Der viele Ruhm, die High Society.
Haben, was man wollte ...
Völlig ein anderes Leben.
- Auch dekadent?
Ah, ja.
Nur dem Besten nachzugehen ...
Zum Glück kam ich zwischendurch
immer wieder zurück auf den Boden.
Furrer scheint mir
recht zufrieden mit dem,
was er im Leben erreicht hat - ob
mit Geld oder in jungen Jahren ohne.
Ein Grundstein dafür
waren die Jägerweisheiten,
die er hier
von seinem Vater gelernt hat.
Die älteren Jäger nennen ihn immer
noch so: Das ist der Furri-Posten.
Von hier haben sie
auf beide Seiten gesehen.
Wer früh aufstand, den Arsch
in Bewegung setzte und wusste,
wo der beste Posten ist,
war auch der Erste beim Posten.
Das ist im Leben wichtig: zur
rechten Zeit am rechten Ort zu sein
und dann mit den richtigen Leuten
richtig zu reden.
Ein kurzes Konzept,
aber es funktioniert.
Gut.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Geld macht nur glücklich,
wenn man damit etwas machen kann.
Sei es, den Leuten zu helfen.
Sei es, selbst etwas zu machen.
Aber glücklich ... Geld ist Papier.
Nichts mehr. Papier.
Ein Wermutstropfen bleibt.
Seine Nachkommen haben den Betrieb
der meisten Hotel- und Gastrobetriebe
kürzlich eingestellt.
Sie sind dabei,
Teile des Erbes zu verkaufen.
Wie es weitergeht,
ist derzeit in Abklärung.
Ist der Traum geplatzt?
Träume gehen nicht immer auf.
Jemand kommt und führt es fort.
Auch das hier
wird irgendjemand weiterführen.
Wir haben sechs Enkel,
man kann viel wünschen.
Aber auch das ist
nicht unglaublich wichtig.
Der Name Furrer und die Hotelkette
wird nicht von heute auf morgen
vergessen gehen.
* Schleppende Musik *
Macht Geld glücklich?
Dieser Frage gehen wir nach.
Jetzt fehlt uns noch eure Meinung. Wie seht ihr das?
Was sind die Vor- oder Nachteile?
Schreibt eure Meinung gerne in die Kommentare.
Das war die Geschichte
von Art Furrer.
Ein Leben lang gearbeitet,
ein Imperium aufgebaut,
das keines von den Kindern will
und verkauft werden muss.
Wie wirkt eine solche Geschichte
auf dich?
Ja, das ist einfach ...
Es kommt natürlich darauf an,
ob ...
... ob er gut loslassen kann,
wie gut er loslassen kann.
Oder wie stark er
damit verbunden ist.
Wenn jemand gut loslassen kann,
ist es kein Problem. Weg ist weg.
Ist glücklich zu sein
das falsche Ziel im Leben?
Geht es nicht darum,
glücklich zu sein oder zu werden?
Das ist wichtig.
Man muss nur schauen,
wo man das Glück sucht.
Nicht im Vergänglichen,
sondern im Unvergänglichen.
Es kommt eigentlich nur darauf an,
wo man das Glück sucht.
Muss man es aktiv suchen
oder findet es einen?
Wenn du es nicht schon hast ...
Auch wenn du es schon hast,
musst du es noch suchen.
In Form von ...
Es muss einem bewusst werden,
was für ein Glück man hat.
Manchmal muss man einander
auch aufs Glück aufmerksam machen,
das man hat.
Wir haben genügend zu Essen und zu
Trinken. Wir sollten glücklich sein.
Aber warum sitzen morgens alle
übel gelaunt im Zug?
Das ist die Frage.
Eigentlich sollten alle
Halleluja sagen
und ... wie in Afrika ...
irgendwie unterwegs und ...
Ja.-Ja.
- Wo ist das Problem?
Ganz arm bleiben
oder ganz reich werden.
Für die meisten von uns
stellt sich die Frage nicht.
Wir leben irgendwo dazwischen.
Unser Reporter Simon Christen
porträtiert zwei Menschen,
die für sich selbst
herausgefunden haben,
dass es am Ende nicht
um entweder-oder geht,
sondern darum,
einen sinnvollen Mittelweg zu finden.
Stefan Geisse: einstiger Kadermann,
heute Yogalehrer und Stresscoach.
V.a. Führungskräfte
suchen seinen Rat.
In Zeiten von Corona
forciert er den Fernunterricht -
und analysiert das Problem vieler
Manager aus ayurvedischer Sicht.
Sie haben zu viel
vom Feuer-Element.
Menschen, die sehr viel Feuer
in sich tragen,
haben in der Regel sehr viel Power,
sehr viel Energie,
sehr viel Willen
und sehr viel Umsetzungskraft.
Man kennt es aus dem Bekanntenkreis
oder aus dem Büro.
Es gibt Menschen,
die gehen da einfach durch.
Die kämpfen
und haben sich ein Ziel gesetzt.
Sie haben viel Energie, Power
und einen starken Willen,
um diese Ziele zu erreichen.
Diese Menschen sind oft in Konflikt
mit anderen, mit Situationen
und oft auch mit sich selbst.
Das merke ich auch
in meinen Beratungen.
Menschen, die sehr viel Feuer in
sich tragen, sind nicht zufrieden.
Tipptopp.
Was sie an mir schätzen - da ich
auch aus der Wirtschaft komme - ist,
dass ich ihre Situation verstehe.
Wir sind auf Augenhöhe,
wir können miteinander sprechen.
Ich verstehe ihre Probleme,
ihre Nöte.
Was ich oft beobachte:
Wenn die Zusammenarbeit
länger dauert,
wenn wir uns intensiver
auseinandersetzen,
dass sich Menschen, die nach aussen
orientiert und erfolgreich sind,
sich auch langsam getrauen,
zu öffnen.
Es geht nicht darum, die
spirituelle Erleuchtung zu finden
und sich von allem Materiellem
loszulösen,
alles zu kündigen und zu verkaufen
und nur noch irgendwie
im Kloster zu leben.
Man kann natürlich
weiterhin sein Leben so führen,
wenn man in bestimmten Aspekten
auf sich achtet.
Was tut einem gut,
was sollte man vermeiden?
Marina Passet
hat schon als junge Frau erkannt,
was sie vermeiden möchte:
zu viel arbeiten.
Gut tut ihr dagegen das Reisen.
Nun wird sie pensioniert
und will die Welt umsegeln.
Man soll das Leben nehmen,
wie es kommt.
Das ist wichtig, aber immer
mit einem gewissen Respekt.
Vor Menschen, der Natur,
anderen Tieren, vor Kindern.
Das ist einfach wichtig.
Die Route steht,
nun testet sie das Equipment.
So.
* Mehrfaches Piepen *
"Suche nach Netzwerk".
So, nun wird gesucht.
Meine Crew darf
nach der ersten Woche auf hoher See
nach Hause anrufen und sagen:
"Ich lebe noch."
"Es geht mir gut."
Sie dürfen 1-2 Min. telefonieren,
das mir dann egal.
Denn es tut ihnen gut.
Wen rufen Sie an?
- Niemanden.
Warum nicht?
- Wieso?
Wen soll ich anrufen?
Vielleicht einmal Verena Bütler, um
ihr zu sagen, dass alles okay ist.
Also Ihrer Vermieterin?
- Ja.
Freundin und Vermieterin.
Darf ich fragen:
Beziehung, Familie, Kinder -
hat Ihnen das nie gefehlt?
- Nein.
Klar: Nein!
Stefan Geisse
war erfolgreicher Manager -
bis er mit 40 eine Hirnblutung hatte
und sein Leben änderte.
Geld verdienen
will er aber weiterhin.
In meiner heutigen Position ist mir,
wenn's ums Materielle geht,
schon auch
ein gewisses Einkommen wichtig,
dass ich mir
bestimmte Dinge leisten kann.
Ich konsumiere sie aber anders,
das ist der Punkt.
Natürlich konnte ich damals nicht
sagen, das sei nicht mehr wichtig.
Ich hielt lange daran fest.
Lange, lange.
Ich habe auch lange versucht,
in der Situation, in der ich war,
etwas zu ändern,
was auch eine Lösung sein kann.
Aber ich konnte mich
in diesem sehr kompetitivem,
sehr wettbewerbsorientierten Umfeld,
in dem es viel um Rendite,
um Gewinn und Gewinnmaximierung
ging, nicht mehr einbringen.
Das war ein langer Prozess
und stellte mich
vor grosse Herausforderungen, klar.
Wie verdiene ich Geld
und bin gleichzeitig glücklich?
Auf diese Frage
ist er erst mit 40 gekommen.
Ich war 13 Jahre in der Schule,
studierte fünf Jahre,
dann zwei Jahre MBA.
Ich war fast 20 Jahre
im Schulsystem.
Da hat mich kein einziger Lehrer
oder Professor gefragt:
"Stefan, wie möchtest du leben?"
Ganz spannend ist ...
Darf ich es zeigen?
(Lachend) Sicher.
- Du weisst noch gar nicht, was.
Das ist mir jetzt
spontan eingefallen.
Da wir über Glück reden.
Ich weiss nicht, ob du's
beim Reinkommen gesehen hast.
Immer nur so viel arbeiten, dass es
für die nächste Reise reichte -
das war jahrzehntelang das Lebens-
und Glücksmotto von Marina Passet.
Mir kommen gleich wieder die Tränen,
wenn ich das anschaue.
Wieso?
Weil es einfach so schön ist,
wenn man ...
... einfach diese Sachen sieht.
Woah!
Ah!
Das sind einfach Wind, Wellen ...
Einfach ... schön.
V.a. die Karibik ist irrsinnig.
Weisst du,
wenn du solche Dinge siehst.
Das Wasser ist einfach genau so.
Einfach bleu - in verschiedenen
schillernden Farben.
Hach! Da wird es einem richtig warm.
Reisen, das ist etwas,
das ich machen muss -
und zwar so lange,
bis ich tot umfalle.
Für mich ist Glück eigentlich,
Dinge beobachten zu können,
auch andere Menschen, andere
Kulturen. Das befriedigt mich.
Befriedigung heisst für mich
auch Glück, glücklich sein.
Ich bin nicht der Meinung,
dass es darum geht,
spirituelle Erleuchtung zu finden,
indem ich in der Höhle meditiere.
Das kann ich machen, wenn ich
im Himalaya aufgewachsen bin
oder wenn das meine Aufgabe ist.
Meine Aufgabe hier in Zentraleuropa
ist aber eine andere.
Daher brauche ich schon einen
gewissen finanziellen Wohlstand,
den ich für mich definiere.
Ich beobachte oft Menschen,
die immer sehr klare Antworten
haben wollen, absolute Antworten.
Ich glaube, das Leben
ist komplexer und vielschichtiger.
Das entscheidet jeder für sich.
Dem Zusammenhang
zwischen Geld und Glück
ist auch die Wissenschaft
auf der Spur.
Mathias Binswanger beschäftigte sich
intensiv mit dem Thema Glück.
Er ist Professor für Volkswirtschaft
und Glücksforscher.
Direkt die Frage:
Macht Geld glücklich?
Wenn ich kein Geld habe,
macht mich Geld sehr glücklich.
Wenn ich aber krank im Spital liege
und schon viel Geld habe,
macht mich noch mehr Geld
überhaupt nicht glücklich.
Es kommt auf die Situation an.
Wie korreliert das Wirtschafts-
wachstum mit unserem Glück?
Ab dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
florierte die Wirtschaft.
Wurden wir auch immer glücklicher?
- Nein, wurden wir nicht.
Aus Japan und den USA haben wir
die Zahlen seit den 50er-Jahren,
die zeigen: Die Menschen sind heute
gleich glücklich oder unglücklich
wie sie es in den 50er-Jahren waren.
Es gibt keinen Zusammenhang mehr
zwischen ansteigendem Einkommen -
im Durchschnitt -
und auf der anderen Seite
dem Glücksempfinden der Menschen.
Das gilt nur
für höher entwickelte Länder.
In ärmeren Ländern
ist das nicht der Fall.
Grundsätzlich
kann man Folgendes beobachten:
In hoch entwickelten Ländern
wie der Schweiz
werden die Menschen im Durchschnitt
nicht glücklicher,
wenn sie
ein noch höheres Einkommen haben.
Das kommt vor in Ländern mit einem
durchschnittlichen Einkommen
von etwa 20'000 $ im Jahr.
D.h., in Ländern,
die unterhalb dieses durch-
schnittlichen Einkommens liegen,
führt das Wirtschaftswachstum dazu,
dass Menschen glücklicher
oder zufriedener werden.
In Ländern wie der Schweiz,
die weit über dem Wert liegen,
führt im Durchschnitt
mehr Einkommen nicht mehr dazu,
dass man glücklicher
oder zufriedener ist.
Woran liegt das?
Das liegt daran:
Wenn die grundsätzlichen Bedürfnisse
gedeckt sind -
wenn ich genügend zu essen
und ein Dach über dem Kopf habe -
werden zunehmend andere Dinge
zentral für das Glück des Menschen,
die nicht mehr unmittelbar
mit dem Einkommen zusammenhängen.
Auf der anderen Seite
müssen wir auch sehen,
dass es noch etwas Zweites gibt:
In einem Land
sind die reichen Menschen
immer glücklicher
als die armen Menschen.
Das heisst:
Das sog. relative Einkommen
wird zunehmend wichtiger.
Habe ich nicht genügend zu essen,
ist mir relativ egal,
was andere machen.
Ich will erst selbst genug haben.
Sind meine Grundbedürfnisse
aber mal einigermassen gedeckt,
fange ich an, links und rechts
zu schauen, was die anderen haben.
Dann hängt das Glück
auch stark davon ab,
wie viel ich
im Vergleich zu anderen habe,
ob ich mit den geltenden Standards
mithalten kann.
Zum einen sind die Reichen
glücklicher als die Armen.
Zum anderen werden wir trotz stei-
gender Wirtschaft nicht glücklich.
Ist das nicht ein Widerspruch?
Es scheint ein Widerspruch zu sein.
Man kann das vielleicht anhand
eines Beispiels kurz illustrieren.
Stellen wir uns
ein Fussballspiel vor.
Alle Zuschauer
beobachten das Geschehen sitzend.
Einer sieht nicht viel, weil der
vor ihm gross ist. Er steht auf.
Jetzt hat er einen Vorteil
gegenüber den anderen.
Er sieht, was passiert
und ist glücklicher.
Das ist aber kein
langfristiger Gleichgewichtszustand.
Entweder
muss er sofort wieder absitzen,
oder hinter ihm, links und rechts
von ihm stehen andere auch auf.
Alle sind auf einem höheren Niveau.
Trotzdem hat sich die Situation
für niemanden verbessert.
Die Grossen sehen wieder gut,
die Kleinen schlecht.
Alle kamen auf ein höheres Niveau,
trotzdem hat sich die Situation
für den einzelnen nicht verbessert.
So ist es auch beim Einkommen.
Welche Tätigkeiten oder Beschäfti-
gungen machen besonders glücklich?
Menschen sind grundsätzlich
meistens dann glücklich,
wenn das Sozialleben funktioniert.
Man ist glücklich in dem Moment,
in dem man mit anderen zusammen ist
und etwas machen kann -
nicht permanent,
es gibt auch viel,
das man gern allein macht.
Die meisten Menschen
sind aber auf Dauer nicht glücklich,
wenn sie alles allein machen.
Auch wenn man
etwas allein gemacht hat,
will man den anderen zeigen,
was man gemacht hat.
Es ist weltweit so:
Wenn das Sozialleben
gut funktioniert,
sind die Menschen
meistens glücklich.
Der Mensch ist ein Herdentier und
kein einsamer Tiger im Dschungel,
der auf diese Art glücklich ist.
Viele arbeiten ganz hart,
um erfolgreich zu werden
und mehr Geld zu verdienen.
Das würde diesem Ziel
ja widersprechen,
mehr mit anderen zusammen zu sein.
Ja, das widerspricht dem Ziel,
weil oft genau die Zeit dazu fehlt.
Weil man sich entscheidet,
vorwärts zu kommen,
besser werden
und Karriere machen will,
gerät das Sozialleben tatsächlich
häufiger unter die Räder.
Man merkt erst zeitlich verzögert,
dass man keine Freunde hat,
dass das Sozialleben
eigentlich nicht so toll ist,
auch wenn man
in einem tollen Haus wohnt,
eine Villa besitzt
und tolle Autos fährt.
Am Schluss fehlt genau das.
Die Wissenschaft zeigt:
Reiche Menschen sind im Verhältnis
zu Menschen, die weniger haben,
glücklicher -
wie ist es in der reichen Schweiz,
wenn man zu jenen gehört, die
weniger haben? Wie lebt man dann?
Unser Reporter Christof Franzen
stellt uns zwei Frauen vor,
die mit weniger auskommen müssen.
Einst hatte sich Danica Graf
ihren Traum erfüllt:
Ein eigenes Tierheim
und sogar ein Pferd.
Aber Unglück und Gewalt
warfen sie zurück.
Jetzt verdient sie sich ihr Überleben
u.a. als Verkäuferin
einer Strassenzeitschrift.
Ich habe sehr viele
traumatische Dinge erlebt.
Und ...
In der einen Partnerschaft z.B.
erlebte ich sehr viel häusliche
und sexuelle Gewalt.
Dadurch musste ich mich
stationär behandeln lassen.
Ich war zweimal in Kliniken und ...
... konnte ein Zeit lang
nicht arbeiten.
Und ...
... es wurde schwierig,
wieder Fuss zu fassen.
Grüezi. Möchten Sie auch eines?
- (Frau) Ja.
Seither lebt sie mit wenig Geld
in einem teuren Land.
Ich esse kaum Fleisch
und kaufe Dinge im Sonderangebot.
Kleider auf dem Flohmarkt -
wenn es wieder mal einen gibt.
So kann man sparen.
Danica Graf
lebt mit ihrer 19-jährigen Tochter,
die eine schwierige Zeit durchmacht
und auf ihre Unterstützung
angewiesen ist.
Die 2-Zimmerwohnung
für ca. 1'000 Fr. Miete
fand sie dank Beziehungen -
ein Glücksfall.
Für eine wie sie ist die
Wohnungssuche ein Spiessrutenlauf.
Man hat halt wenig Auswahl.
Man schaut in Zeitungen
und im Internet und weiss genau,
bis 1'000 oder 1'100 Fr.
darf sie kosten.
Wenn möglich zwei Zimmer, damit
die Tochter ein eigenes Zimmer hat.
Wenn man die Wohnung besichtigt,
heisst es gleich,
ich hätte kein rechtes Einkommen -
man würde sich melden.
Dann wird meistens nichts daraus.
Der Coiffeursalon Haarscharf
von Stefanie Schaub
im thurgauischen Amriswil
ist wieder offen.
Aber Corona und Lockdown
sind nach wie vor zentrale Themen.
Konnten deine Töchter
immer normal arbeiten?
Nein, sie haben beide Kurzarbeit.
Ha. Dann warst du die Einzige,
die normal arbeiten konnte.- Ja.
Es ist schon schön,
wenn man Lohn erhält.
Mhm.- Ich habe
alle meine Kunden vermisst.
Hast du mich auch vermisst?
- Ja, sicher.
* Lachen *
Kein Coiffeur,
das ist eine Katastrophe.
Am 17. März musste Salonbesitzerin
Stefanie Schaub
ihr Geschäft schliessen -
auf Anordnung des Bundesrates.
Es folgte eine Zeit der Unsicherheit
und des Bangens
ums Überleben ihres Ladens.
Aus heiterem Himmel
fielen alle Einnahmen weg.
Aber die Ausgaben blieben:
für Miete, Versicherungen,
Schuldzinsen und den Alltag.
Reserven hatte sie fast keine.
Ich habe jetzt vielleicht
1'000 Fr. auf dem Konto.
Ich kann mir überlegen:
Wenn ich die Miete
und die Versicherung bezahle,
was kann ich sonst noch bezahlen?
Ich müsste alle anrufen und sagen:
"Sorry, ich kann nicht zahlen."
"Ich wäre gewillt zu zahlen,
aber ich kann nicht."
Das ist auch ein Punkt,
der einen nicht schlafen lässt.
Die Geldsorgen von Danica Graf sind
kein Ausnahmezustand, sondern Alltag.
Ich war nie obdachlos oder so,
das nicht.
Aber ich hatte nie viel Geld.
Es wäre schön,
in die Ferien fahren zu können.
Aber wenn's nicht drin liegt,
liegt's nicht drin.
Rund 1'500-2'000 Fr.
verdient Graf monatlich.
In diesem Basler Fachgeschäft
für Wohnbedarf
hat sie ein kleines Pensum
als Verkäuferin.
Aber der Laden läuft schlecht.
Die Kunden kaufen lieber
in Deutschland oder im Internet.
Es droht der Jobverlust.
Ähm ...
Dann müsste ich aufs Sozialamt.
Dann käme ich gar nicht mehr durch.
Ich müsste gleich etwas anderes
finden oder aufs Sozialamt.
Für mich ist die Sozialhilfe
wieder eine Abhängigkeit.
Abhängigkeit hatte ich lange
in einer Partnerschaft.
Das will ich nicht mehr.
Ihr Chef Michael Büchler
versucht denn auch,
Graf so lange es geht
auf der Lohnliste zu behalten.
Er kennt ihre schwierige Situation.
Ah, weisst du was?
Die Bandagen ...
Für Schweizer Verhältnisse würde ich
sagen, dass sie eher arm ist.
Sie lebt wirklich ...
Sie kommt gerade so durch.
Sie ist trotzdem sehr aufgestellt.
Sie ist sehr positiv.
Und sie ist nicht jemand,
der jammert.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Der Coiffeursalon von Stefanie Schaub
in Amriswil
hat den Corona-Lockdown überlebt
und ist seit Ende April wieder offen.
In der Schweiz können nur
reiche Leute Ferien machen.
Dieses Jahr gibt es keine Ferien.
Dieses Jahr wird es für alle ...
- Nein, die buchen ja wie gestört.
Ja?
- Jesses Gott!
Die buchen wie gestört.
-  In der Schweiz oder im Ausland?
Schweizer, Deutsche, alle zusammen.
- Okay.
Trotz finanzieller Engpässe
während der Corona-Zeit:
Geld sei weiterhin
nicht das Wichtigste in ihrem Leben.
Ich möchte alle Rechnungen
und alles bezahlt haben.
So ist es ja nicht, nur ...
Ich lebe ohnehin nicht im Luxus.
Ich brauche kein Boot
oder noch ein Auto dazu -
oder vier verschiedene Autos.
Es ist halt einfach ...
Es ist nur Geld.
Reicher werde ich
jedes Jahr ein bisschen.
Egal, ob an Geld oder an Erfahrung.
Glückliche Stunden ...
Ich habe lieber hier
gute Geschichten
als mehr Geld auf dem Konto.
Das finde ich viel schöner.
Es gäbe natürlich Sicherheit,
wenn ich mehr hätte, das ist klar.
Es würde schon etwas ändern.
Das sicher.
Denkt man an eine neue Krise,
oder würde wegen Corona
wieder alles schliessen,
würde es schwierig für jene,
die nichts oder nicht viel haben.
Glück sieht sie aber v.a. darin,
anderen Menschen helfen zu können.
V.a. solchen, die auch
traumatische Gewalterlebnisse hatten.
Ich kann anderen Menschen viel von
meiner Lebenserfahrung weitergeben.
Zuhören und für die Leute da sein,
sie auf dem Weg begleiten.
Das ist das, was ich könnte.
* Melancholische Musik *
Das Coronavirus trifft auch
die Schweizer Wirtschaft hart.
Konjunkturforscher prognostizieren
uns eine ziemlich tiefe Rezession,
einen Konjunktureinbruch.
Die Steuereinnahmen werden sinken.
Dafür steigen die Ausgaben
für Soziales.
Mathias Binswanger,
wie wirkt sich das
auf den Glücksindex der Schweiz aus?
Gar nicht.
- Gar nicht?
Andere Länder hat es auch getroffen.
Wir werden im nächsten Jahr
dieselben Menschen sein,
die wir jetzt sind.
D.h., solche kurzfristigen
Änderungen in der Wirtschaft
haben keinen grossen Einfluss.
Das ist für mich erstaunlich.
Für Sie nicht?
Nein, für mich ist das
nicht erstaunlich,
weil wir alle damit rechnen, relativ
schnell aus dieser Krise zu kommen.
Würde sie längerfristig andauern,
hätte es Auswirkungen.
Aber wir haben eigentlich
alle das Gefühl,
dass es im nächsten Jahr
wieder aufwärts geht
und dass es
ein kurzfristiges Phänomen war.
Das hat keinen nachhaltigen Einfluss
aufs Glück der Menschen.
Arm und glücklich. Geht das zusammen?
Ja, wenn die Armut
selbst gewählt ist.
Wenn ich mich selbst entschliesse,
auf einen gewissen Reichtum
zu verzichten,
weil mir materieller Besitz
nicht wichtig ist.
Dann kann das
eine Quelle des Glücks sein.
Wird mir die Armut aber
durch äussere Umstände aufgezwungen,
macht sie meistens keine Freude.
Wenn wir sagen,
dass die armen Menschen
z.T. so glücklich sind ...
In anderen Ländern.
- ... wenn wir dorthin reisen.
Das hängt
mit etwas anderem zusammen:
Diese Menschen
haben die unglaubliche Fähigkeit,
aus wenig viel zu machen.
Sie verstehen es gut, aus wenig Geld
ein glückliches Leben zu gestalten.
Wir dagegen,
in Ländern wie der Schweiz,
sind hingegen Weltmeister darin,
aus viel wenig zu machen.
Wir geniessen das Leben nicht,
obwohl wir in einem hohen
materiellen Wohlstand leben.
"Geben ist seliger denn Nehmen",
steht sinngemäss in der Bibel.
Stimmt das?
Macht weitergeben von Geld glücklich?
Dazu muss man es erst einmal haben.
Ist man arm, hat man kein Geld.
Dann ist das ein zynischer Spruch.
Wenn man viel Geld hat,
dann ist es z.T. so.
Wenn man sieht,
dass man mit dem Geld, das man gibt,
etwas Positives bewirken kann
oder Menschen glücklich macht,
ist es für einen selbst
eine Glücksquelle.
Wenn aber man auf Dauer feststellt,
dass man nur gibt
und nie etwas bekommt,
kommt man sich
schnell einmal ausgenützt vor.
Das macht
auch nicht unbedingt glücklich.
Es braucht auch hier eine gewisse
Balance zwischen Geben und Nehmen.
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
Guido Fluri, ich habe
noch nie einen Menschen gesehen,
der frei grasende Ponys
auf seinem Rasen hat.
Ist das die Exzentrik
eines Multimillionärs?
Na ja,
die Ponys sind nicht
aus diesem Grund hier.
Das war für die Kinder.
Die Kinder haben auch
sehr viel mit den Ponys unternommen.
Sie mussten auch zu ihnen schauen.
Sie haben sie geputzt,
sind früher auf ihnen geritten.
Ich denke, das ist ein Teil,
der ihnen in ihrem späteren Leben
bleiben wird.
Du bist in dieser Sendung
mit Abstand der Reichste.
Darum die Frage an dich:
Was ist toll daran, so reich zu sein?
Was ist toll am Reichtum?
Ich glaube, Reichtum ...
Geld ist vielleicht das Falsche,
um den Reichtum zu benennen.
Ja, es ist eine angenehme Situation,
wenn man Geld hat.
Hat man viel Geld, hat man
auch eine grosse Verantwortung,
einen Teil an die Gesellschaft
zurückzugeben. Das ist klar.
V.a. jemand wie ich,
der in jungen Jahren
nicht in einfachen Verhältnissen
aufgewachsen ist
und immer anschreiben musste.
Im Laden?
- Ja, auch.
Meine Mutter ...
Wir sind oft in der Schweiz
umhergezogen und hatten nie Geld.
Man nahm unsere Möbel,
weil wir die Rechnungen
nicht bezahlen konnten.
Diese ausgelieferte Situation,
in der wir damals waren,
ist sehr tief verwurzelt.
Kein Geld zu haben und in schwie-
rigen Verhältnissen zu leben ...
V.a. zu jener Zeit,
in jener Generation,
in den 60er- und 70er-Jahren.
Das war für mich
eine schlimme Erfahrung.
Jetzt hast du
dieses riesige Grundstück,
Seeanstoss
und so viel Geld auf der Seite.
Hätte man dich als kleinen Jungen
gefragt, wie Glück aussieht,
hättest du dir so etwas vorgestellt?
Nein.
Ich habe das auch nicht
in dieser Dimension angestrebt.
Für mich war immer ...
Ist man der Situation ausgeliefert,
nichts zu haben,
wird man angetrieben,
selbst Sicherheiten zu erarbeiten,
um nie mehr
in eine solche Situation zu geraten.
Ich weiss noch ...
Noch als 25-Jähriger
öffnete ich das Portemonnaie,
schaute rein und hatte das Gefühl,
es reiche nicht.
Und sogleich ist es mir
etwas warm geworden.
Ich hatte Angst, wieder in
die Situation wie damals zu kommen,
als mir meine Mutter sagte, ich
solle der Frau an der Kasse sagen,
sie solle es aufschreiben.
Was ist das für ein Gefühl?
Sehr beklemmend und auch ängstlich,
ausgeliefert zu sein.
Man fühlt sich wertlos.
Dieses Gefühl hatte ich
bis weit über mein 25. Lebensjahr.
Das ist ein Antrieb, diese Situation
nie mehr entstehen zu lassen.
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
Guido Fluri hat es zu einem Vermögen
von mehreren 100 Mio. Fr. gebracht.
Sein Start ins Leben
war allerdings schwer:
Er kam als uneheliches Kind
einer 16-jährigen Kellnerin zur Welt
und wuchs in Heimen auf.
Trotzdem schaffte er
einen fast märchenhaften Aufstieg.
Meist ist Fluri
im Laufschritt unterwegs.
Er eilt von Termin zu Termin,
von Erfolg zu Erfolg.
Was er anfasst,
scheint ihm zu gelingen.
Ich spüre das einfach,
würde ich mal behaupten.
Man kann auch
nicht viel falsch machen:
Man steigt einfach dann ein,
wenn sonst niemand einsteigen will.
Aber "nicht viel falsch machen" -
wäre es so einfach,
wären viele Leute
so erfolgreich wie Sie.
Das ist offensichtlich
nicht der Fall.
Es gibt sehr erfolgreiche Leute,
ausserordentlich erfolgreiche.
Man muss ein bisschen Mut haben,
das ist sicher so
bei solchen Geschäften.
Aber ich würde nicht behaupten,
dass das ein grosses Talent sei.
Das sehe ich nicht so.
Was ist denn Ihr grösstes Talent?
Ich bin ein guter Tänzer.
Fluri war ein Schulversager.
Besonders schlecht war er im Rechnen.
Besonders gut ist er
u.a. bei Immobiliengeschäften,
womit er mit Anfang 20
mit geliehenem Geld anfing.
Z.B. in der Zürcher Innenstadt.
Das wäre eigentlich ...
... der Bereich, in dem ...
... ich immer
ein bisschen tätig war.
Man sieht hier an der See- und an
der Gotthardstrasse mehrere Objekte,
die übernommen worden sind.
Was haben Sie hier investiert?
Meinen Sie die Kosten?
- Ja.
Das waren um die 4 Mio.
Das Gebäude wird heute
auf ca. 20 Mio. geschätzt.
Eingestiegen ist Fluri
in den 90er-Jahren -
mitten in der Immobilienkrise.
Als alle verkaufen wollten,
kaufte er.
Der Markt erholte sich irgendwann,
die Preise explodierten -
und Fluri wurde reicher und reicher.
Sie möchte Ihnen
einfach unendlich danken.
Im Dorf wird davon gesprochen.
In Ihrem Dorf
wird darüber gesprochen?
Wie gross ist das Dorf?
Fluri engagiert sich
schon lange karitativ.
30 % seiner Gewinne fliessen
in die Guido-Fluri-Stiftung.
Davon profitieren u.a.
Menschen mit Hirntumoren,
in diesem Fall
ein Mädchen aus Brasilien,
das er zusammen mit den Eltern
in die Schweiz geholt hat,
um es in einer Privatklinik
von einem Starchirurgen
operieren zu lassen.
Auch für all diejenigen,
die in der Schweiz im 20. Jh.
Opfer von behördlicher Willkür
wurden, engagiert sich Fluri.
Unter dem Titel
administrative Versorgung
wurden
die Grundrechte von Betroffenen
jahrzehntelang systematisch verletzt.
Lange wehrte sich die Politik
gegen eine ernsthafte
historische Aufarbeitung
und wies eine finanzielle
Wiedergutmachung weit von sich.
Das änderte sich
unter Simonetta Sommaruga
als Vorsteherin
des Justizdepartements.
Die Politik war unter Druck geraten,
weil Guido Fluri über 100'000
Unterschriften gesammelt hatte
für eine Initiative,
die Wiedergutmachung forderte.
Die Schweiz
entschuldigte sich offiziell
und sprach einen Solidaritätsbeitrag
von 25'000 Fr pro Opfer.
Damit endete
ein jahrzehntelanger Kampf.
Fluris Engagement geht weiter.
Kürzlich ist er auf
die griechische Insel Lesbos gereist
und hat das Flüchtlingslager Moria
besucht.
Die Zustände entsetzen ihn.
Er will versuchen,
an diesem Elend etwas zu ändern.
Das ist ja kein ...
Tiere haben es schöner.
Könntest du dir vorstellen,
hier zu leben?
Das kann sich niemand vorstellen.
Und die vielen Kinder,
die es hier überall hat.
Sie haben keine Schule.
Erwachsene, starke Männer,
die Kraft und Energie haben,
die arbeiten
und etwas bewegen könnten.
Sie sind nirgends integriert
und liegen herum,
in diesen verwahrlosten Hütten.
Ich kann es nur noch einmal betonen:
Es ist ein Versagen der Politik.
Zu uns - zum Multimillionär
Guido Fluri - ist ein Mann gestossen,
den wir schon kennengelernt haben.
Christoph Trummer lebt als Eremit
in selbstgewählter Armut
im Berner Oberland.
Ich kann es vorwegnehmen:
Ihr habt euch während des Beitrags
schon angefreundet.
Bei dir habe ich
einen gewissen Neid gespürt.
Das Leben von Christoph Trummer
als Eremit.
Was würde dir zusagen?
Was mich sehr ...
Ich bin beinahe etwas neidisch.
Diese Lockerheit, diese Freiheit,
die er in sich spürt.
Kein Zwang,
kein Rucksack auf dem Rücken.
Man fühlt sich doch frei,
wenn man genügend Geld hat.
Dann hat man auch Ansprüche.
Man hat Ansprüche,
etwas verwirklichen zu wollen.
Das betrifft zumindest mich.
Das schafft auch Verantwortung,
das schafft Druck.
Man will etwas realisieren.
Ich finde,
wenn man so frei ist wie er ...
Ich muss sagen,
es ist beeindruckend,
auch wie er das Leben gestaltet.
- Ja.
Wie anders nahmen dich
in deinem Empfinden die Leute wahr,
als du zu den Armen gehörtest,
gegenüber jetzt,
wo du zu den Reichen gehörst?
Merkst du, dass die Menschen
anders mit dir umgehen?
Selbstverständlich.
V.a. in jener Zeit, als man
in jungen Jahren das Gefühl hatte,
dass das mit dem Burschen
ohnehin nicht funktioniere.
Man bekam immer wieder
das Gefühl vermittelt:
"Du kannst nichts,
aus dir wird nichts."
Das hat man natürlich gehört,
auch wenn man z.B. die Voraussetz-
ungen für ein Studium nicht hatte.
Aber heute
hat man eine andere Situation.
Heute hat man mehr Anerkennung,
man hat mehr Aufmerksamkeit.
Das ist schon so.
Es gibt eindeutig
eine Parallele.
Wenn man im Leben über sich hinaus-
wächst und etwas erreichen kann,
hat man mehr Anerkennung,
als wenn man
in schwierigen Verhältnissen lebt.
Wie ist es bei dir?
Bekommst du Sprüche zu hören
von Menschen, die sagen:
"Was ist das für einer?"
Es ist jetzt 30 Jahre her, dass ich
aus Indien zurückgekehrt bin.
Das habe ich natürlich
alles hinter mir.
Das geht von Verurteilung bis hin zu
man müsste mich an die Wand stellen.
Alles so in dem Sinn.
Weil man einfach nicht mitmacht.
Du passt nicht
in das Gesellschaftsbild.
Ich zahle keine Steuern.
Ich zahle keine Krankenkasse.
Ich bin sozial nicht abgesichert,
und, und, und.
Äh, ja ...
Und, voilà. So.
Aber daran wächst man auch.
Ich bin hier in der Schweiz
noch nie für etwas betteln gegangen.
Ich war immer selbstständig.
Ich habe gesunde Arme, gesunde Füs-
se, einen gesunden Kopf - relativ.
Und ich bin allein.
Wo ist also das Problem, das zu
unterhalten? Es ja nicht viel.
Wann macht denn Geld nun glücklich?
Das ist die Frage unserer Sendung.
Macht Geld glücklich,
Christoph Trummer?
Wenn man es sinnvoll, für das Leben-
dige, einsetzen kann, dann sicher.
Geben macht glücklich -
so steht es auch in den Schriften.
Gib, dann wird dir mehr gegeben,
nicht?
Ich bin christlich aufgewachsen.
Ich habe schon im Mutterbauch
Predigten gehört.
Dort heisst es auch irgendwo ...
"Was nützt es dir, wenn du
die ganze Welt gewonnen hast,
wenn du die Liebe nicht hast?"
Das ist eigentlich das Wesentliche.
Ob man ein Fünfrankenstück hat
oder Millionen,
spielt gar keine Rolle.
Wenn der mit den Millionen
die Liebe im Herzen spürt,
und der mit dem Fünffrankenstück
sie nicht spürt,
ist der mit den Millionen
viel weiter, mit dem Geld,
mit der Liebe zusammen, als der
andere mit dem Fünffrankenstück.
Guido Fluri, hast du überhaupt Zeit,
dieses Glück zu empfinden?
Das Glück, das du hier hast,
dieses Privileg - hast du Zeit?
Für mich ist es eher ein Abschalten,
ein Regenerieren.
Ja, das kann ich ziemlich gut.
Ich kann regenerieren.
Aber regenerieren, nur um
dann noch mehr arbeiten zu können.
Ja, weisst du ... Leistungen ...
Wenn du Resultate willst,
wenn du wirklich einen Fokus
und etwas erreichen willst,
auch im sozialen Bereich -
wirtschaftlich wie sozial,
dass wir z.B. heute
über meinen Reichtum sprechen -,
musst du Vollgas geben.
- Da musst du knallhart sein.
Auch dir selbst gegenüber?
- Ja, sicher.
Irgendwann musst du auch die Verant-
wortung für dich selbst übernehmen.
Vielleicht zahlst du irgendwann
auch den Preis dafür.
Tribut, du zahlst Zoll.
Ja, du kommst irgendwann
an deine Grenzen.
Damit muss man ...
Damit muss man rechnen.
Das gehört dazu.
- Ist es das wert?
Nein, ist es nicht.
Aber da kommen wir wieder
zum Inhalt des Lebens.
Das Sinnbild des Lebens.
Jetzt bist du noch gesund,
hast Kraft, Energie.
Jetzt kannst du etwas bewirken,
das für dich wichtig ist.
Und da funktionieren
Halbherzigkeiten nicht.
V.a., wenn du
von nichts emporkommst.
Christoph Trummer,
wenn du dir dieses Haus ansiehst ...
Denkst du,
du würdest hier leben wollen?
Das würde schon gehen.
Da liesse es sich schon leben.
Es ist trocken im Inneren und so.
Ich würde sofort
eine grosse Wohngemeinschaft machen.
Eine Kommune.
- (Lachend) Eine Kommune.
Hier Gemüsegärten.
Ich würde alles pflügen.
Gemüsegärten.
Ökologisch natürlich, bio.
Ist es vertretbar,
dass jemand nur mit der Partnerin
in einem so grossen Haus wohnt?
Da ist er nicht zu beneiden - wenn
ich da nur ans Saubermachen denke.
Guido Fluri,
wenn du wieder arm werden würdest -
hast du das Gefühl,
du wärst trotzdem glücklich?
Schwierig.
Wenn man etwas aufgebaut hat
und wieder von vorne beginnen muss.
Sich in diese Situation
zu versetzen ...
Es ist schwierig zu beantworten,
wie man sich da fühlt.
- Also eher nein?- Eher nein.
Das wäre ganz schwierig.
Denn man hält sich
auch am Erreichten fest.
In erster Linie sicher
auch bei den sozialen Themen,
wo man mit Geld etwas bewirken kann.
Etwas verändern, bewirken zu können,
ist eine grosse Genugtuung.
Dann kannst du
das plötzlich nicht mehr,
weil dir die Mittel fehlen,
um etwas zu bewegen.
Das ist nicht ganz einfach.
Bist du glücklich?
Es gibt Momente,
in denen ich sehr glücklich bin.
Wenn meine Frau und meine Kinder
bei mir sind, meine Schwiegereltern.
Dann habe ich
sehr glückliche Momente.
Das ist aber eigentlich
unabhängig vom Geld.
Ja, das ist nicht vom Geld abhängig,
nein.
Denn in diesem Moment ...
Sicher ist es schön,
gemeinsam auf dieser Wiese zu sein.
Das kann man
auch in einer kleinen Wohnung,
sich aneinander erfreuen.
Ich denke, dieser Moment,
einander zu spüren, das ist Glück.
Füreinander da zu sein, ja.
Das ist ein schöner Moment.
- Ja.
Christoph Trummer, bist du glücklich?
Ich bin sehr glücklich,
dass ich dieses Leben ...
... so leben durfte,
wie ich es erfahren durfte.
Und v.a., dass ich bin, was ich bin.
Das ist das grösste Glück:
einfach zu sein, was man ist.
Diese Genügsamkeit, das ist
das Glück. Diese Genügsamkeit.
Da steckt
aber auch viel Arbeit dahinter.
Ja, sehr viel.
Das ist beeindruckend.
Da ist er viel weiter als ich,
würde ich behaupten.
Du bist stärker getrieben.
- Zusammen ergäben wir ein Ganzes.
Ich bin viel stärker getrieben.
Da könnte ich
sehr viel von ihm lernen.
Ja, zusammen ergäben wir ein Ganzes.
Wir werden dann mal
bei dir ein Bierchen trinken.
Ja, das wäre interessant.
Wie viel oder wie wenig brauchen wir, um glücklich zu sein?
Eure Meinung fehlt noch. Ab in die Kommentarspalte damit.
Ich empfehle euch noch einen DOK-Film über Minimalisten.
Menschen, die sich bewusst einschränken. Und beispielsweise nur mit 64 Gegenständen leben.
Für mehr solche Sendungen einfach den DOK-YouTube-Kanal abonnieren und die Glocke aktivieren.
So bleibt ihr auf dem Laufenden.
Vielen Dank für eurer Interesse und bis bald!